welcome back to new rockstars the new
trailer for venom let there be carnage
gave us our first look at woody
harrelson as cletus cassidy serial
killer who
loves to doodle but how will carnage get
his powers exactly and once he does
what's his plan i'm eric voss this is
rogue theory the show where we speculate
on all the things we're a little too
obsessed with
whitney today is an amazing panel of
returning rogue theory guests starting
with
new rockstar zone mt and it is his
birthday today
happy birthday my friend thank you thank
you to everybody may 13th is my birthday
so
thank you i feel a lot older um i mean
i'm still bald but
i feel older you can tell the oldness on
the inside with the bones
creaking um mostly yeah but yeah you
hear where it sounds throughout the
broadcast that is mt's bones yeah that's
just so
the wind hitting me and my bones
creaking in the wind also
also back on the show is my favorite
symbiote or
as she pronounces it symbiote jessica
clements
hello hello hello happy birthday mt
is a storm a coming or is that just your
knees are cracking
[Laughter]
option two jess option
and welcome back writer and comedian
erica wusu
hey hey hello internet people and happy
happy birthday oh thanks homie oh my god
you guys we're a family
yes we are and uh this family's gotta
talk about carnage because
we just met cletus cassidy uh in this
venom let there be carnage trailer we
first saw him back in the post-credits
scene of the first venom when he had
that sideshow bob do
uh but now he's in this trailer for the
sequel we're seeing a lot more of woody
harrelson
as both the imprisoned serial killer
cletus cassidy
and his new form the symbiote carnage
but
we don't see in the trailer how that
symbiote
and cletus cassidy come together we
haven't understand the comics where
you know eddie brock and cletus share a
prison cell and then
venom helps eddie escape but then leaves
a little goo a little goo behind and
then
that you know
uh but like how's it gonna happen in the
movie like uh
is it gonna be some kind of weird fluid
swap when eddie visits them in prison
they just make out yeah we're gonna get
a big
uh kiss and venom's like oh i wanna know
yeah it was like i liked making out in
the first movie let's do it again
oh well it has to be
it has to be during that interview right
or well like
it doesn't have to be but i don't think
it's going to be like the same as in the
comics where he's like
making a shank and trying to stab him
but i think
and also in the trailer since we see
carnage coming out of woody harrelson's
body when he's going when he's about to
die
it has to be between that time of like
interview to him being killed
so it has to be in that interview like
maybe he comes too close
and then they fight and then the
security guard pulls him away
i don't think that old man would but i
think eddie brock would move away
and then the fluid is left on him the
symbiotic like it has to be in there
it can't be it can't be like in the
comics
it's a good point jessica you're right
it has to happen in that um
period of time but it brings up two
questions there one
uh did could it have been that cletus
already had it through some other means
oh but two if it is passed on from eddie
why does the venom symbiote leave eddie
is it just like if you touch him for too
long it passes on it seems like there
has to be kind of a choice
of that passage correct yes also before
anyone else goes i will say real talk
i don't think the null has anything to
do with it yet that's all
that's weird is that too
rogue i just think i know i don't think
i okay so what we what we have in the
comics right
well cletus was born and he was like i'm
on a mission with
like noel was the one that was in the
hospital so i don't think we're gonna
get any of
knoll yet noel's too big to come in that
soon
that's how i feel someone else you okay
okay someone else take it away i just
think that
it's like that's going to be further
down the line because
that's like eternal celestial stuff
that's like 100 so
big that we can't and this movie is a
association with marvel it's not a
it's not like marvel film i don't think
it's going to show up or a peeler in the
mcu necessarily it's still sony so i
just think it's not gonna be
they're not gonna let noel like come in
like that but someone else take away
please go ahead
um i do wanna touch on the nel thing
when we have when we continue our
conversation um
in regards to the mcu connection okay
yeah i totally agree
that nell will not play a factor in this
film because he's too big of a character
but i do think that this movie is
setting up a null
type situation um just just because of
like
just the four or four coming out and
like with the uh the necro sword and
like
they're they're going to really get into
the period of time before the big bang
where it was all darkness because that's
where the venom symbiotes come from it's
that
that time where um there was just
nothing in the universe
that darkness so we're definitely gonna
have that
probably tie in but like anyway we
should probably focus on the actual
question that i had without done
it is a good
but yeah so i think that this this uh
with venom and riot and all the
symbiotes they come
from um the the beginnings of the
universe in this universe as well as
in um in toby maguire's universe because
the symbiote does live there
so i think they're all these universes
have the same um
origin in time in terms of um this
darkness creating
the the symbio and also again the
necrosaur that we're going to see
in thor 4 um wielded by gore um
so i feel like they're going to really
just emphasize that that um the origins
of the symbiotes
um with um moving forward with null so
going yeah going back to
how do we get carnage in this movie film
that's coming out in association with
marvel but mostly
uh i i think these movies especially the
sony marvel movies
they kind of small scale what happens in
the comics
so i think with the origin of carnage
because you know in the comics eddie
brock and cletus
such a funny country stupid name stupid
name
oh no watch out his cleanest he's got a
ladies
games until he kills a bunch of animals
you guys come on
yeah it's like it's like roadkill that
he's bringing home to eat like a cletus
put down that dead possum
cleaners
but anyway so cletus in this carnage
movie the let there be carnage venom two
i think
what will happen the key to him becoming
carnage will be
the little letter that goes back and
forth between eddie brock
and cletus because in the in the trailer
uh we see eddie brock is looking at this
little letters like white but with red
writing on it
and you know this is while venom tucks
them into the table and squirts the
ketchup and all that stuff is happening
so i think somehow someway a little bit
of the venom eddie brock symbiote
symbiote uh gets onto that letter uh and
then it gets back to cletus somehow
and somehow some way either that's how
cletus gets it or
on one of the visits that eddie brock
takes and goes to the
san quentin prison to visit cletus he's
a prisoner
maybe he does fashion some sort of shake
and
kind of shank eddie real quick or try to
get some
dna i think mainly because cletus
because he's you know mentally disturbed
and you know has some issues
he sees or senses eddie brock a
difference or change in eddie brock
and how he might maybe he's talking to
venom
but misspeaks the way when eddie brock
goes into the convenience store he kind
of misspeaks to miss chen
and says hey venom says what's up so
maybe something like that happens when
eddie goes to visit cletus in prison to
get more
interview stories of you know torturing
and killing people and khalees was like
huh
two people were talking to me let's see
what this is about i think he
i feel like he had he had to have the
powers before because in the trailer he
also which i don't know in the timeline
of what the trailer the dialogue is in
but in the trailer he mentions like we
have a lot in common a lot more than you
think eddie brock
so maybe he like like eddie brock
obviously can't hide the fact that venom
like
is inside of him so i think he's just
like acknowledging like
we both have a lot of similarities i
have a symbiote
you would you say i call it boss you
said i call it a symbiotic
i have a symbiote
there could be that possibility that i
guess it could lay dormant in him
until something happens um but i feel
like even
in a hole in my theory is when he's
writing his name and blood with his
finger
nothing's being triggered so i don't
that's why i'm like
i don't know i think he had it when
coming into the prison because why else
would he say that being like we have a
lot in common i also only want you to
interview me
because i know your secret but then how
does he get his that's why
that's why i'm like i'm trying to figure
out where he got him from unless
like well okay so like what if he okay
so
this is me pulling things off my ass so
this is the symbiote is basically
so he could have got it from anything
essentially
it like right it could have been in it
could have been attached to someone else
a host prior
that didn't work and yeah when he was on
a killing spree maybe it attached to him
and laid dormant
um but then i guess how about how about
this you got someone who works for the
life foundation jenny slate's character
who kind of does one of these charles
manson relationships with someone
with like the serial killer in prison
it's like i love you cletus
here take this and he's just like i'm
i'm more into shrek
but okay
could he have met her before she went
into ravencroft
because then that that could be because
it's like they had some pre-existing
relationship
those two right yeah some carnage
there could be a part of the trailer we
just haven't seen yet that is the
beginning
which is like when he is on a murdering
spree maybe he got attached by someone
he murdered
i will stick my guns for that i think
right now we don't fully know but i
would
believe that someone he killed prior had
that host
and maybe he didn't initiate the
symbiote was like i'm not gonna defend
you
or something because you're weak and
jumped on to cletus that way
yeah that's my again i think you're
right with the timeline there jessica i
don't think uh cletus cassidy was
carnage yet i don't think he had the
symbiote yet when uh eddie visited him
in that post-credits scene
just because he would have escaped you
know if he already had the capacity to
do it he would escape
but i do think like he has this idea of
carnage in his head he's just a deranged
deranged sadistic killer so um i
but what i do think is that somehow
through this connection with eddie
uh i don't think i think we're done with
the light foundation for now even though
they did have some of the other ones it
was really only that riot
uh symbiote that was successful i think
uh and i think that's done with for now
it's gonna be through eddie somehow and
yeah and then through one of their
repeated visits to write this story
somehow some piece of him got off and
then latched onto it and then he's just
kind of
biting his time but i wonder what's the
activation is it just a lethal injection
that only now it finally activates i
don't know if this
if there's any uh precedent for this
this probably isn't but like what if
there's a piece of carnage
that like went inside of like um if why
am i
like on his name cletus uh what if there
was a piece of carnage that went inside
of cletus at like an early age
and like that was the reason why he
became a murderer oh
crazy yeah and so like and so when he is
about to be executed the thing's like
all right i'm going to activate now
because
my life is in danger and so like he was
sustaining himself from the murders that
cletus was doing he's like yeah this is
good enough for me
and then um i was like all right now i'm
going to mature into
carnage that's it
i mean that would suggest mt that like
there's a previous
extraterrestrial arrival on earth
because at the beginning of venom it
showed the light foundation brought all
these samples back right
you don't have to say like car carnage
has a completely different origin on
earth
that arrived through some other
meteorite and then you know yeah like
it's like oh something happened some
explorers opened up a cave and here
comes carter the
red gloop and here comes garnet
i like that except for the only part i
don't like about that is i like a good
friendly story and i want him to be
friends with
the carnage though he is a psychopath
and a serial killer i understand that's
not okay
but like he found another crazy thing i
think he needs to have been his own
cereal because that's what makes carnage
so scary is that this human being was
already broken by the time he got his
side fact isn't he um i don't i don't
know if they're gonna go by this in the
movie
but he definitely is much stronger with
carnage because they're both
like on a level of crazy i don't know
i don't want to say crazy i'm trying to
think of like a technical term for this
so if i stutter it's because i'm trying
not to offend
but i mean like when you're talking
about someone like cletus i know you
know that man's insane
he's straight up he's a murderer
that's why he's like so much stronger
than venom is because it's like oh
venom and uh venom and brock are just
like they still have their like
miss like they're like sometimes but
carnage
and cletus are both freaking insane are
like yeah i just want to murder
like i just want to kill i want
destruction so i think they
they do need each other that's how they
like find each other so i do agree with
umt i think that'd be fun if that's like
we've been friends forever like we've
been we've been crazy together
but yeah i just think that's a side note
that is also important to keep
but we should talk more about null
because empty i think you are right on
that front i
think that's going to inform some of
what carnage's plan
is like imagine why do you cast woody
harrelson that guy's so
aloof and detached from reality he's
kind of a hippie you know and that's
what's so fun about him
like you can imagine you can give this
guy any dialogue and he'll just make it
sound sensible as if this is something
he's believed to his core
like you know i keep picturing woody
harrelson in that movie 2012 where he's
just like
up in a mountain cabin somewhere on
radio
just like this is
but like that guy can make it work and
like imagine once he gets infected with
this
symbiote and like somehow he just starts
hearing voices and that voice from
beyond is a voice of null
telling them he's like no you have to
make drones build me an army build me a
following
you know build me a block or whatever
like that i kind of feel like that's
going to inform it's not just going to
be carnage just like
burn the world down i think he's going
to try to establish
his own world order and would carnage do
that
yeah well i guess what he doesn't have
absolutely but i don't know if
carnage carnage would be like well i'm
just going by the absolute carnage run
where he's in san francisco he's
people in san francisco and he's kind of
building uh a deadly army of drones it's
just trying to like
destroy everything but like it's his own
kind of like
um what sort of it's its own nihilistic
approach to what noah believed
like he kind of subverts and dethrones
no and yeah
they wanted i think and what i mean
correct me if i'm wrong mt i think you
know that better than i do
i mean like i i as far as i know nell's
main goal was to
um basically the forward the dark world
thing where like just bring
the world back to darkness back to the
right time before the big bang
so uh i i haven't read
um absolute carnage which is like
something on my to-do list for this week
it's very like i couldn't tell you but
like i know i've been doing my research
on null and i know that nolan
um malekith are are very similar and um
actually fun fact the reason why i think
um this is a fun little connection
between venom and the mcu
the reason why the ether is a sludge
is because it was um made before the
time before the big bang because there
was nothing
there was no form so they either flood
except sludge
it's why the uh symbiote is a sludge
because
the darkness was um
before the big bang was formless so like
or like literal uh what's it called
plasma
primordial ooze yeah it's like
primordial plasma that um
no fat like uh used up for a celestial
forge to forge into the necro sword
um so it's yeah so i love that sentence
and he said it's where we can get forged
the necro sword
this is why uh girls don't know how to
answer my texts back it's like he's
going to talk about forging the neck
results
you just haven't found the right girl
that's all yeah their name is eric voss
if you text them
they'll text back like erica boss
erica voz
want to see this necro sword real quick
i'm disgusted give out the points
give out the points well this has been a
fascinating conversation
uh i'm not surprised you three you nerds
you guys have great ideas
well jessica i'm going to give you a
point for just being
on that timeline you understand uh the
chronology of events and how that's
going to affect so you get a point for
being
our team time is not a construct
it's a flat circle uh i think you and i
are thinking on similar wavelengths with
this postcard thing i think that's gonna
be very important the fact that he wrote
it in blood
and i think that might be how the you
know the
contamination occurs so i'm going to
give you a point as well
mt for being all over this null theory
and bringing a necro sword in there i'm
giving you two points
what the hell thank you you know you
know what i love
all right we have to move on at this
point so
we're gonna get some thoughts on how let
there be carnage could tie into sony's
bigger plans for how they want to
pretend like they're in the mcu but
first a few words from some folks who
helped us make rogue theory
actually uh first shout out a quick
thank you to our merch partners epic
hero shops where you can find some great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
including
an additional shirts and hoodies and
stuff like that we got hats we got water
bottles
perfect for the months when you want to
stay hydrated try to sneak into a museum
exhibit with nobody recognizing you as
steve rogers so you can get all this
stuff at newrockstarsmerch.com uh we
want to thank our friends at upstart for
sponsoring this episode
paying off debt can feel like an uphill
battle high interest rates can keep you
in an endless cycle of debt
upstart can help you get out of that
cycle and get ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment
upstart looks at your income and your
employment history instead of just your
credit score
this means it can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five-minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front
for loans between 1 000 and 50 000
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payment
today when you go to upstart.com rogue
theory that's upstart.com
rogue theory don't forget to use our url
to let the know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
theory we also want to thank credit
karma money for sponsoring this episode
when it comes to free stuff quicker is
better right well with credit karma
money
you can win cash reimbursements for
debit purchases
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases when
you use your credit karma money debit
card you can win
daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to
five thousand dollars just pay it off
with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified
on the spot and your instant karma cash
will be added back to your
spend account credit karma money has
given away over 3 million dollars in
instant karma to over 50 000 members
open your fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirements no overdraft fees
and free withdrawals from a network of
over 50 000 atms
right now visit creditkarma.com win
money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning with instant karma
that's credit card.com money instant
karma sponsored by credit karma no
purchase necessary exclusions in terms
of supplies banking services provided by
mvb bank inc member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limit
supply and of course you gotta thank
your prince at bluetooth for sponsoring
us
bluechoo has a unique online source that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
bluechu is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
so licensed medical providers work with
you to find the right ingredient in
strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news blue chewable is
chewable just like it says in the name
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we've got a
special deal for our audience
try bluetooth free when you use the
promo code rogue at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month for free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast okay guys
let's talk about venom and how it's
gonna connect to sony's bigger plans
uh in the mcu because we know sony
partners with the marvel studios team
for events like
spider-man no way home which could be a
major event of some kind
that both marvel the mcu it takes place
in the mcu but it is a sony production
so they can do whatever they want with
it they can put whoever they want in
this movie
and they're they're showing that they're
putting in alfred molina
from spider-man 2 the rainy era they're
bringing in jamie foxx
all right the mark webb era so andy
circus the director of this movie
clarified that the characters of
venom let there be carnage are unaware
of spider-man's existence
but what's a little confusing to a lot
of people is we got this other movie
morbius living vampire coming out with
jared leto uh
and that trailer came out early 2020 and
you know in that movie
sony appears to try to make that super
tight
with the mcu like we got michael keaton
the mcu's vulture
gonna appear in this movie all these
other clues pointing to spider-man being
the accused murderer that he was at the
end of far from home in the mcu
so how is venom let there be carnage
gonna thread this needle uh is uh is it
gonna tie
into spider-man no way home at all do we
think no way home might reference the
events of venom two
do we think venom or carnage could show
up in no way home
i think that if anyone's gonna show up
anywhere it's probably going to be peter
parker
showing up in the venom universe being
like uh listen up eddie we need your
help and that's
all we're going to get they're just
going to figure it out
between then and their spider-verse
plans but i think that like the main
thing that we're going to get from venom
2 is just a spider-verse tease
because you know you're right like
people are confused as to
what universe venom is even in and then
like why are they even making venom
movies if
if they don't seem to line up with these
future spider-verse plans
so i think that this movie has sort of
like a
almost like an obligation for sony to be
like oh okay guys here's here's where
venom is
in regards to our own whole plan so yeah
i think we're gonna see
tom holland show up at the very end
be like hello everybody it's me tom
orland it's me
american tom i agree with mt
i know wild um but i i agree with mt i
think ultimately
but it wouldn't it suck to have another
situation where we have tom holland
showing up and just saying like eddie we
need you
and it's the same as we got with
childish gambino i hate to be the bearer
of bad news but i think it's gonna be a
fun side movie for us fans that love
venom
i think it's just gonna be like you guys
can go to venom it's going to be great
you can also go to the old fantastic
force it's going to be great but it's
not going to be associated with
what's going on in the mcu right now i
think it's just going to be a movie on
the side
and i also felt that way a little bit
about morbius but i understand
why like peter parker is like the
the medium for all of this but i just
think it's like
it's just like you oh did you like this
person we're giving them a movie well
morbius morpheus might pop up in blade
way down the line but i think
i think they might troll us in this next
mobius movie by having wesley snipes
just pop oh yeah
for no reason but not be blade
[Laughter]
he's like a big teller i i'm
uh yeah the realist in me kind of sides
with you there jessica i think
realistically andy circus is directing a
movie for sony
and john watts is directing a movie for
for sony as well
but like he's more in tied in with kevin
feige and his plans
but like what's weird is in both of uh
john watts previous spider-man movies
they
i want to talk to who on that set is
putting in these little references
to the reimy era like the fact that they
had that sign
for you know uh bone saw mcgraw in
in far from home it's like someone there
who decided to put
um jk simmons at the end of far from
home was that john watts
was that amy pascal was that aviarad
like there's someone at sony who wants
this interconnectivity to happen
uh and i have a feeling that uh
while a crossover of the actors may not
happen we may get a little tease
to carnage's existence of reference to
san francisco or something like that
to the ravencroft institute in and
no way home uh and i think it's actually
more likely for
that to happen in no way home than venom
let there be carnage
just for like budgetary reasons like i
don't know i would imagine
andy circus's budget for let venom let
there be carnage just
under 100 million um those movies
they're
they're not spending a lot of money on
them but spider-man no way home
that's gonna have over 200 million maybe
close to 300 million
budget sony is gonna pour money at this
especially now that disney's
co-financing it
for 25 they're gonna be like oh now we
basically have twenty percent more of a
budget
we didn't have before great let's spend
that money to make this a huge
movie and cross in everything we can
yeah it did really well so i
this yeah right was inevitable and they
even teased
cletus at the end of the first one so
but i think
venom two will function a lot like the
disney plus
tv shows where they're giving someone a
side kind of side character who's not a
main mcu person
their own kind of time to shine so this
will kind of function like the captain
america winter soldier
of the sony verse in association with
the marble verse
uh so i don't think there will be any
connective tissue
other than maybe a stan lee cameo and
and
so you know with uh jk simmons popping
up is j jonah jameson and the daily
bugle
with the infoworld style at the end of
spider-man uh far from home
and all these other little things that
they're putting in is
promo because even if they don't like
make good on
putting that person in the subsequent
film
it gets us talking it's like oh my
goodness jk simmons
is tobey maguire going to be in the next
spider-man movie like this is basically
marvel sony whoever putting two prize
fighters
nose to nose right before a fight like
even if nothing happens after that it
gets
us talking and it gets us super excited
and it gets eric boss to make
conspiracy theory type videos and us to
have this platform to talk about what
may or may not happen so
everyone wins from them putting these
little easter eggs and whoever the
decision maker is
that you were talking about you know
they're like oh if we put this person
there
this is gonna happen then whoa it's not
and they'll be wrong
uh i'm just gonna give you the point
right now
that is exactly really what sony is
doing i don't
think they think that i think they're
just like it'll be fun
it'll be fun it'll get the fans excited
and they're good
but he put it in such clear terms and he
compared it to disney plus
which i think is right
yeah yeah
yep but i do think uh cynically that
is it i think they just look at it all
as fan service and they're like
let's just give something to the fans
and i don't think they think that
broadly about the implications of it
uh which is fine and you're right it
does give us more things to talk about
here on youtube so
i wish we gets the point uh but we're
gonna move on to rogue questions
uh because we have some questions i
wanna hear from you guys about
uh first off james gunn teased this week
that there will be
multiple post-credit scenes to his
suicide squad film later this summer
so i want to know from you what is your
most rogue guess for
what will be in one of those suicide
squad post credit scenes
um well hopefully um it's
it's a post-credits scene with
ratcatcher because she survived because
she's my favorite
character in the whole uh team and if
she dies i'm gonna be heartbroken
i got one i think nathan fillion's
probably gonna be the first one to go
and when nathan filian goes
i think he's gonna get blown up and
they're just gonna assume he's dead
and then the post credits he's gonna be
alive but then uh
king shark eats him i like it
i think i think they're gonna put in
deathstroke for zero reason
so on that one i'm gonna give jessica
the point uh
i think that was a good idea of having
king shark eat the detachable kid i
think it'd be funny
all right second question walking dead
creator robert kirkman is producing a
movie about renfield
dracula's assistant written by former
new rockstar's guest ryan ridley
and i think he wrote on invincible as
well that guy is great
so the question is what do you think is
the best job perk of being dracula's
assistant
i mean if you are also a vampire i i
don't know if this character is also a
vampire but i guess you get like
free blood probably i don't know yeah or
sloppy stuff
you know i don't wanna i don't wanna be
this person to do the call back
but the benefits seem like they'd be
very well to be an assistant to dracula
um not only are you never gonna get
murdered because you're
literally the assistant to the number
one murderer
but you never have to worry about food
or a place to sleep
because you're the assistant to dracula
so the benefits i stole
woo-woo's earlier answered it's okay
i'll allow it
i don't know i think my favorite thing
for working for dracula is you know
it is a job and i hate how during day
jobs you know i can't do anything
i can't go to the bank i can't get my
laundry done until like weekends or
nights
but now it's only daytime hours i have
available so
that's great that for families that
sounds awful
you're like i get to do everything in
the morning and everything at night
uh yeah agreed so i'm gonna give that
point to empty i think the blood the
extra blood is the benefit there making
empty our winner oh shoot so birthday
boy
because you're a cheater
i lied it's not actually my birthday i
only have said it to win
i knew it
[Laughter]
if you lie about it being your birthday
it's still it still counts all right
no it's actually my birthday can we do a
rogue video on my birthday
sure uh well that's it for this episode
of rogue theory i want to thank all of
our guests mt jessica clements erica wu
follow all of them on their social media
support them in their many projects you
can support our channel by checking out
one of our many great merch options at
new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe here on youtube and we'll see
you next time bye-bye everybody
bye sweetheart later
[Music]
you